déménager à la campagne c'est le choix
qu'a fait la famille de luigi prizzoti
temporairement juste installé sur la
table de cuisine grâce au télétravail
la famille a pu quitter définitivement
montréal mme auger a lancé me supérieur
puis ont pris ça très très très
ouvertement d'un bon gré en fait si on
trouve que c'est une bonne idée une
bénédiction pour la famille on est
superbe et son envie pour les grosses
fesses de montréal
ici les oiseaux peuvent jouer dehors et
ont toute la place plusieurs employeurs
ont été forcés d'opter pour le
télétravail durant la pandémie
une tendance qui semble vouloir perdurer
mon client moi justement des côtes julie
je cherche je cherche tel type de
candidat et puis ce pas ce que cela peut
venir de n'importe où
non seulement au canada mais aussi aux
états unis nous on a transféré notre
business 100% télétravail un virage
positif à moins d'en profiter pour
précariser davantage les travailleurs
je vous envoie à travers la maison mais
comme travers autonome sans les
avantages que vous en avez je peux aussi
préconisé le travail comme je prendre un
poste que j'avais ici au bureau et que
je veux juste simplement délocaliser
dans un autre partie du monde où je peux
payer moins cher avec moins de droits
l'association télétravail québec veut
contrer ce phénomène en demandant la
modernisation de la loi sur les normes
du travail
pour le professeur il faudra aussi que
les employeurs revoient leur mode de
gestion
il faut qu'ils les emplois brise avec
une mentalité avec des philosophies de
gestion qui les utilisent même
aujourd'hui mais qui sont ancrées dans
les 19ème 20ème siècle le télétravail
c'est beaucoup plus qu'un ordinateur sur
le coin d'une table qu'on installe un
bureau luigi prévoit aménager son espace
de travail pas question de revenir en
ville à temps plein le vp est
fonctionnel cinq minutes travail c'est
super ça ça n'a pas de prix pour lui et
sa famille la pandémie aura été
l'occasion de se construire une
meilleure vie ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal